ich fordere heute abend die
kirchensteuer muss abgeschafft werden
wir brauchen eine ganz klare trennung
von politik und religion das ist in
deutschland nur theoretisch so praktisch
wird die kirchensteuer vom staat
eingezogen er setzt auch die kirchlichen
feiertage fest und bezahlt die bischöfe
wie beamte das ist teilweise nicht wenig
im fall von woelki sind das mehr als
13.000 euro denn er fällt in die
besoldungsgruppe b ich selbst bin
katholikin und ich zahle auch
kirchensteuern noch muss ich sagen denn
seit dem letzten missbrauchsskandal habe
ich wirklich
sorge dass ich mein geld eine
männerverein gebe der missbrauch
vertuscht woher soll ich denn wissen
dass mit meinem geld nicht etwa anwälte
bezahlt werden die mutmaßliche
kinderschänder verteidigen ich weiß es
nicht wir wissen es nicht denn wir haben
keinen einblick in die finanzen der
kirche ich habe also im dunkeln was mit
meinem geld geschieht ich sehe einfach
nur jeden monat wird es mir von meinem
konto abgezogen und dieser eindruck
durch das finanzamt das ist wirklich
eine deutsche spezialität das ist in
keinem anderen staat der staat
unterstützt die kirche also unterstützt
sie dann aber wiederum nicht wenn es um
die aufklärung von
rechtsverstößen dreht wie zb missbrauch
das klärt der verein dann lieber unter
sich dann schickt er irgendwelche
abgesandten aus rom nach köln die
sondern alles unter die lupe nehmen aber
glaube ich denn wirklich dass dabei die
wahrheit ans licht kommt also ich glaube
es nicht und dieses hinter den
geschlossenen türen agieren das ärgert
ja nicht nur mich 400.000 deutsche sind
2020 aus der kirche ausgetreten und ich
denke wir müssen die kirchensteuer jetzt
abschaffen damit es nicht noch schlimmer
wird damit die kirche überhaupt gerettet
werden kann denn nur dann wenn sie
selbst sich um ihre spenden zu kümmern
hat dann wird sie wieder demut lernen
dann wird sie wieder eine verbindung zum
volk aufbauen können sie muss rauskommen
aus dieser ewigen bequemen nehmer
position und den menschen wieder etwas
anbieten also abschaffung der
kirchensteuer
wenn sich die kirche nicht ausblutet das
war ja nicht gerechnet so dass war
charmanter zorn gerechter zorn er war
charmant vorgetragen yvonne ich stimme
dir voll und ganz zu ich bin auch
kirchensteuerzahler
natürlich wenn aber bei den protestanten
also bei denen die martin luther quasi
zum licht geführt hat ärgerlich aber
ebenfalls immer wieder darüber vor allen
dingen dann wenn ich wieder mal ein
gottesdienst gewesen wenn das passiert
ab und zu und eigentlich meinung habe
ich bin ich auf dem grünen parteitag
gewesen das muss man sagen passiert in
der evangelischen kirche immer wieder
immer wieder immer wieder das mag ein
bisschen anders in der katholischen
kirche seien aber auch da stellt sich
natürlich immer wieder die frage warum
zahle ich einig wenn ich gar nicht
parteimitglied bin dann für eine partei
beschallung die ich gar nicht bestellt
habe und ich glaube der punkt den mast
ist deswegen ganz richtig die kirchen
müssen den druck spüren die erneuerung
der katholischen aber ebenfalls die
erneuerung der protestantischen kirche
die kann nur gelingen wenn es sich
automatisch geld gibt sondern wenn sich
die kirche aktiv bewerben und wirklich
darum vielleicht erst betteln muss an
geld zu kommen denn dann ist sie in der
lage und in wird zwangsweise in eine
situation versetzt wo sie sich um die
dinge kümmern muss die ihren mitgliedern
wichtig sind und nicht um die sache
richtig in den eigenen den pastoren
wichtig ist weil jetzt im also ist es
stört sie nicht dass der staat die
steuern 1000 sondern sache haupt steuern
gibt ja so sie jetzt zwar zwei themen na
ja das sind zwei themen aber man könnte
nun sagen die software variante wäre es
gibt noch kirchensteuern aber da sorgt
sich nicht der start war gut aber wenn
du hier drüben daran könnte dass er
unbedingt den spende oder dem lesen ich
könnte selber bestimmen wie viel ich der
kirchen ich wurde am abend noch spannend
wenn ich entscheiden könnte ich gebe
mein geld bin offensichtlich nicht
kirchenmitglied ich bin mitglied einer
jüdischen gemeinde weinfelden und juden
fahren kirchensteuer in deutschland es
geht aber eine jüdische gemeinde am ende
ja ich würde nämlich gerne zu wenden an
welche genaue synagoge oder an welches
programm oder ähnliches ich mein geld
gebe so dass sie mich überzeugen müssen
ich finde die struktur schon ganz
angenehm und auch die verbindenden
elemente aber wenn ich die möglichkeit
so habe zusagen den kindergarten würde
ich gerne unterstützen oder dieses
bestimmte programm finde ich super dann
hat man wieder ein bedürfnis
orientiertes leben in der kirche fahren
darf er die gefahr nicht sehr sehr groß
dass das dann gar keine kirchen und
synagogen mehr gebe weil erst einmal
also wer
etwas spendet ihr dann wenn jetzt die
die steuer entfällt etwas spendet ihr
dann eure kirchen das ist doch mal
ehrlich so hypothetisch tragen als
würdig erhält deswegen steuer besteht
aber ich glaube der punkt ist ja also
wenn man zahlt kirchensteuer und dann
geht am ende eines gottesdienstes oder
mittendrin immer nachher mit
klingelbeutel durch zu einem besonderen
zweck
für brot für die welt nahe anderes mag
es ist auch so dass die kirche
tatsächlich auch ein männerproblem hat
dass man sich wahrscheinlich da sind die
mehrheit frauen in der in dem ja
aber meine vier jeder katholischen
frauen zum priesteramt zuzulassen weil
viele probleme um die kirche jetzt hat
hätte sie nicht wenn frauen dort das
sagen hätten und ehrlich gesagt in
meinem gerade wurde mein mein sohn hat
der kommunion die ganze arbeit haben die
frauen gemacht das hat die
gemeindereferent gesagt den priester hat
er erst gesehen es am tag der kommunion
vorher war er nie zu sehen hat nie etwas
macht es gibt auch in deutschland extrem
viele bis 60 stück oder so aber die
repräsentieren ja durch die ganzen aus
dritte es gibt ja gar nicht mehr so
viele gläubige was können wir da alles
an geld sparen ja das kirner bleiben
nicht eigentlich das kernproblem dass
kirche einen teil dessen wozu sie da
sein sollte nämlich seelsorge den
menschen das gefühl zu geben wenn mal es
schlecht läuft oder wenn das leben zu
ende geht dass da jemand ist der dich
auffängt der dann da ist die
analytische methode
ist mein cockpit 19 uhr waren sie da
schweigen im walde sind
aber das hat jetzt auch wieder nichts
mit der steuer zu tun also
darüber dass eine kirche die für eine
aufgabe da sie nicht erfüllt und warum
soll ich sie dann wird's aber warum soll
denn jetzt anständig arbeiten würden
bekämen wir auch kein gehalt gut also
also sie sagen also in dem moment wo sie
die steuern nicht mehr kriegen und gar
kein gehalt
dann würden sich mühe geben aber dann
wäre es halt weg dann wären ja auch die
die fahrer auch nicht mehr da sein und
danach also wie eine organisation die
sich die non profit ist und sich ihr
geld holen muss und zwar mit einem guten
angebot an
ein angebot oder mit einem nutzwert an
die kirchenmitglieder so gut sein dass
wir müssen
das kirche nun der nur der sonntag ist
der verrat irgendwas predigt sondern
kirche macht ja schon noch eine ganze
menge her sie betreibt soziale
einrichtungen und kindertagesstätten und
vieles andere mehr
ob das noch so funktioniert es geht man
könnte es als allgemeine steuersystem
umlegen aber gipfel ist doch
ausdrücklich recht haben uns noch mal
ganz ehrlich das ist ja der
klingelbeutel in der kirche was tun wir
denn da rein da kommt doch keiner auf
die idee dann waren die sich auch nur im
entferntesten in höhe des stollens
klammer viehhändler konzepte wir kennen
doch konzepte international dass
menschen willig sind geld zu geben für
etwas was ihnen wichtig ist ich glaube
auch dass die katholische kirche ein ort
wäre wo menschen gerne geld geben würden
wenn es an orte gehen würde innerhalb
der kirche die für sie relevant sind es
gibt offensichtlich auch da wieder so
ein problem von was brauchen wir und wer
gibt mir das und das kommt nicht
zusammen zu gehen mit dem hund
sachverständiger also sondern vielleicht
eine evangelische kirche eintreten was
war da noch die gleiche argument habe
ich weil ich mich so geärgert haben und
im konfirmationsunterricht russische
friedens tänze eingeübt werden sie
genauso aber der punkt ist wenn wir über
400.000 flächen aus dem gerät eine firma
die 400.000 kunden verlieren würde bei
rund sage mal 30 35 millionen kunden
400.000 das wäre dann schon ein prozent
und das passiert jedes jahr die müssen
sich ja irgendwann fragen habe ich noch
eine existenzberechtigung oder anders
gesagt sie würde wahrscheinlich in
schwere existenznöte kommen und das ist
genau der punkt glaube ich durchaus
ansprechend es gibt gar kein treiber zu
sagen wir müssen was ändern denn diese
kirchensteuer die fließt und
interessanterweise trotz der
kirchenaustritte gab es ja in den jahren
letzten drei vor corona jedes jahr neue
rekordeinnahmen der kirche das ist
ja keine firma die kirche produziert
auch nicht so die kirche hat auch keine
kunden die kirche ist einfach daher ist
mir ein individuelles entscheiden ob die
kirche oder die synagoge
ob sie da sein sollen oder nicht und ich
glaube euch das nicht dass ihr so viel
geld aufbringt ich wiederhole mich jetzt
eigentlich
so viel geld auf
repressive der ganzen instandhaltung der
des des kölner domes das schafft aus
mitgliederbeiträgen wird nicht pleite
gehen vielleicht hat sich unsere unsere
steuern die sind wirklich wirklich
reicht ihr haben die am grund besitzt
sie haben aktien machen sie sich keine
sorgen und die kirche
also es ist sie mitglied der kirche da
sind ja ich bin evangelisch bin aktives
mitglieder wissen wir beide auch
überzeugen und nicht auf ja ich bin auch
noch nicht ausgetreten aber
ich trete auch nicht aus wir gehen
zusammen solltest du jetzt sehr schnell
merken dass wir ihn mal raus haben und
schauen wir mal dass alle den frauen in
dem ich ihn nicht recht weil in meiner
kirche die frauen die frauen die
mehrheit sind also die sind da und wir
machen das war weiß ich nie das grußwort
den frauen sind bei ihm in der kirche
die mehrheit